And this example is now easy.
You can see that all the four over here fit with the green one.
In fact, the separating line will be somewhere here and, in fact,
after the next iteration of optimize, with the assignment of those point, four
points of this cluster center and those three points of this cluster center.
You can see that this cluster center will move
straight into the center of those four points.
And this cluster center will move to the center of those three points.
Have we truly achieved our result?
We now have assumed it's two clusters.
But our algorithm of iteratively assigning and
optimizing has moved the cluster center straight into what we
would argue is actually the correct centroid for those two clusters over here.
That is called the k-Means algorithm.